JENNY SCHIFFMAN: Thank you
guys so much for coming,
and welcome.
My name is Jenny
Schiffman, and I'm
thrilled to introduce
Ilyse Schapiro and Hallie
Rich to talk about
their best-selling book
"Should I Scoop Out My Bagel?"
They're going to answer a
lot of your burning questions
and things about nutrition
that you've been dying to know,
which is perfect
timing for summer.
So Ilyse Schapiro, she's
a registered dietitian
and certified
dietitian nutritionist.
She holds a master of
science in clinical nutrition
and dietetics from
New York University,
and resides in
Mamaroneck, New York.
She's also one of
my closest friends.
I'm personally very
thrilled that she's here.
And Hallie Rich is a trailblazer
in the vitamin industry,
having created the award-winning
AlternaVites brand.
She received her BS with honors
from the University of Michigan
and resides in New York City.
So with that, Ilyse and
Hallie, take it away.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: OK, perfect.
Jenny, thank you so much, and
it's such an honor to be here.
We couldn't be more excited.
And it's kind of crazy, because
I've grown up with Jenny,
so this is amazing.
OK, so introducing the scoop.
So why did we write this book?
Hallie and I kind of sat down
together a couple years ago.
We both said we want
to write a book,
but we couldn't figure out
what we wanted to write about.
And at first it started out
very serious and very technical,
and we both looked at
each other, and we said,
that's not us.
And that's not what
people need right now.
There's too much stuff
out there that's,
you have to cut out gluten.
You have to cut out dairy.
You have to do a juice cleanse.
And one week it's
butter is good for you.
Butter is not good for you.
Eggs are good for you.
Eggs are going to kill you.
So we decided to write
a book and kind of cut
through all the BS, and just
put it down all in one spot
to give you the latest research
and the latest knowledge that's
out there today.
And there's pros and
cons to everything.
And our book is a
guide to allow you
and empower you to
make smart decisions.
Again, there's so much out
there, on the "Today" show.
You can get anything online.
So we're giving you
this information
to empower you to make
the best decisions
to live your best life.
HALLIE RICH: It's not
about dictating to you
how to live your life.
It's about saying
what's important to you
and then making those
healthy decisions.
So if you love carbs,
don't cut out carbs.
But here's ways to
make smarter decisions.
If you're onto protein or
you're afraid of gluten
or you haven't had
a full egg, you've
only had egg whites
for the past 10 years,
we give you, not permission,
but the knowledge
and the information to just
do what's best for you.
And we kind of want to cut out
a lot of the misinterpretations
out there, that food
is evil, that food
is a bad, four-letter word.
You know, food
should be enjoyed.
You only live once.
We're all about
everything in moderation,
and just kind of pick your
vices on where you should enjoy
things and where you shouldn't.
Like we always say, I
can't go without carbs.
Ilyse could give
up carbs tomorrow.
And it was kind of a
really nice mix when
we were writing the book,
because we both came at it
from different ways.
But how do we both enjoy life
and how do we be healthy?
And it's not about being skinny.
And one of the things when
we first wrote our book,
our first publisher
wanted to rename the book
and call it skinny
something or other.
And we actually left
that deal and started--
we worked with the publisher
we're with now, Skyhorse,
because we were
uncomfortable with that.
It's not about being skinny.
It's not about losing the
most amount of weight.
It's about being the
healthiest version of yourself,
and whatever that
is like to you.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Exactly.
Oh, good.
So why listen to us?
Jenny gave a brief bio.
I have my masters
of science from NYU.
I'm a registered
dietitian, which
means I'm certified in New
York state and Connecticut
to practice, which is different
than being a health coach.
I have tons of schooling.
I have to maintain my continuing
ed credits every year.
And I have a private practice
in Harrison, New York
and Greenwich, Connecticut.
HALLIE RICH: I'm the third
generation in my family
to be in the vitamin
industry, so I-- really
actually in my genes.
And really how we
came together, we
were introduced through
a friend to work together
with my vitamin company
and Ilyse's practice.
But what's kind of interesting
is the reason why you eat,
the reason why you
take supplements,
is all about the nutrients.
So whether it's the vitamins,
the minerals, the antioxidants,
whatever it is you're
getting, you're
trying to get the same benefit.
So we actually have
a lot more in common.
It's just a matter of,
where do you get it from?
And I'm of the
belief, as is Ilyse,
obviously you want to try
to get the most that you
can from food.
But whatever you
can't get from food,
you want to try to supplement
with whatever product
it is that works for you.
And that's how we work so
well, because we both know
enough about the nutrients.
It's just a matter of
where you source them from.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: OK.
All right, so we've got
Rainbow Bagels in the back.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, Hallie.
HALLIE RICH: So about
scooping your bagel,
does everyone here scoop?
Do people not scoop?
Are you into scooping?
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
What do we think about scooping?
HALLIE RICH: We're in New York.
Everyone has to eat bagels.
How do you eat them?
Plain, not plain?
All right, well, so obviously
the name of our book
is "Should I Scoop My Bagel?"
And if you're looking
to lose weight,
the answer is yes, you
should scoop your bagel.
The most important thing,
though, with scooping,
is not, when you scoop out
the middle, to eat the middle.
Make sure you throw it out.
Otherwise there's absolutely
no point in scooping.
A good other thing
to do is to toast it,
because it makes
it really crunchy.
You don't really see that
you're missing things.
The other most
important thing is just
not to pour everything in there.
It doesn't become a boat
for you to put extra stuff,
kind of top it off at
the top with a scoop.
Great things for there would
be peanut butter, turkey, even
like a pizza bagel, low-fat
tuna, grilled chicken.
You can make anything you want
of it, because at that point,
it's kind of just bread.
And then if you
don't want to scoop,
if you're at a business
meeting, if you're here
enjoying your
Rainbow Bagels, just
have half a bagel, a
flagel, a little flat.
Anything like that is
a great alternative
if you don't want
to scoop and you're
trying to watch your weight.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
OK, good.
And some people
have said to us, why
would you have bagels at talks?
But again, we're about
everything in moderation.
So enjoy.
Have fun.
And the Rainbow Bagel place
in Brooklyn is amazing.
It has been amazing to us.
OK, so some quick bites,
some quick things.
Again, these
questions we came up
between peers and colleagues,
and for me sometimes it
was somebody at the gym coming
up to me, or my client saying,
what should I do?
And even actually, I was
a huge believer for years,
I thought blotting my pizza
would save a ton of calories.
In fact, it doesn't.
So just enjoy your pizza.
The grease that you soak up only
accounts for 20 to 50 calories.
And you're really only actually
soaking up the moisture.
So we say, you know
what, if you're going
to have pizza, that's fine.
Don't think you're saving
hundreds of calories
by soaking up the grease.
Park a little bit further away.
Or if you're in New York,
walk a couple of extra blocks,
because I think some people
misinterpret, oh, I just
soaked up the grease, so I
can have two to three slices
because I'm saving
tons of calories.
And then another thing
that comes up all the time,
and I'm a huge just
only egg white eater,
more because I just prefer it.
I don't like the
taste of the yolk.
But whole eggs are
making a comeback.
Years ago, everybody was
cutting out the yolk.
It causes high cholesterol,
causes heart disease.
Actually, they're saying
now research says it's not.
If you do have a family
history or personal history
of high cholesterol,
then yes, I would
keep your egg yolks limited,
maybe once or twice a week.
But if you have no family
history or personal history
of high cholesterol, you don't
have to cut out the yolk.
You don't have to be, like
me, that annoying person
in the diner saying, can I have
an egg white only omelette.
It's OK.
Eat the yolk.
And the yolk actually
has all the vitamins.
It has vitamins A, D, E, and
K, though egg white is great.
It has protein.
It has magnesium.
And one thing that we found
out as we were doing this,
especially since I'm
the egg white person,
if you buy the fancy omega-3
eggs, which are great,
you actually only get the
benefits of the omega-3's
if you eat the yolk.
So otherwise, if you're
an egg white only person,
just by the regular cheap eggs,
because otherwise you're just--
HALLIE RICH: Really
expensive egg whites.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
You're wasting your money.
All right, frozen yogurt
is better than ice cream.
Who's a fro-yo person out there?
The big 16 Handles, or some
of those self-serve places.
And again, for years
I was fro-yo girl.
You know, it has less calories.
I can eat as much as I want.
Now, especially with
those self-serve places
and you can just put
in like 16 ounces,
sometimes you're just better
off having just a small scoop
of ice cream.
The small scoop of
ice cream is going
to be way more satisfying
than 16 ounces of air.
And also, at the fro-yo
places, I mean, I'm guilty too.
You put on tons of toppings.
They taste delicious,
but before you know it,
your fro-yo which you
think is super healthy
can be 600, 700, 800 calories.
So again, if you like
fro-yo, enjoy it.
Just try and keep the
portion sizes down,
because ounce for ounce,
it's actually similar.
And the regular ice cream
would be more satisfying.
HALLIE RICH: It's got
your full-fat dairy,
so you're gonna
be more satisfied.
You're gonna be fuller.
And in the book we make an
analogy to that fake purse
that you buy.
First you love it.
Then you see all of
its imperfections.
Then you're like, why'd I
spend all the money on this?
Kind of the same thing
with frozen yogurt.
You see it.
It seems refreshing.
It seems satisfying.
But then by the time
you're done, you're like,
oh, I have the
worst stomachache.
I have gas.
I'm never going to eat it
again, until the next day.
Just kind of be careful with it.
It's deceivingly nutritious, and
it's just a lot of chemicals.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
And I've also had
clients say to me,
oh, Ilyse, I went out for 16
Handles, and then I came home
and I ate-- like,
I was still hungry
and I ate a bag of M&M's,
or I ate a couple of Oreos
because it just-- it
didn't fill me up enough.
So multigrain instead
of white bread.
So I think multigrain
bread is great,
but you have to know
what you're getting.
I think a lot of people
don't read the labels
and assume just because
something's multigrain,
it's actually just as good.
You know, it's whole grain.
But sometimes multigrain
is just a bunch of grains,
and it's not 100% whole grain.
So you have to make sure
you read labels, again,
if this is something that
you are concerned about.
You need to make sure you read
labels, because in some cases
multigrain bread that you buy
in the supermarket package could
be equivalent to white bread.
HALLIE RICH: They just
use some food colorings
like caramel and stuff.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
HALLIE RICH: It looks healthy.
I mean, I was that person.
I bought multigrain
all the time.
Now, after researching
for this book,
I only buy 100%
whole wheat bread,
just because that's
something that, one, I
think it's more satisfying.
It has more fiber in it.
But I also don't
need all the caramel.
It's white bread with caramel
and some nuts on the top.
You know, it's
not what you think
you're necessarily getting.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
Right.
So you need to make
sure on the label
it says 100% whole
wheat, 100% whole grain,
or that the first ingredient
is whole wheat or whole wheat
flour.
HALLIE RICH: So sushi--
we've all had sushi,
whether it's after
work at night,
you order it to your desk.
You probably have it here.
You think it's small bites.
It's healthy.
It's good.
It's a nice balance
of fish and carbs.
But it's kind of
none of those things.
Actually, the rice
that they usually
use for sushi, pardon me,
is full of salt and sugar.
So you're actually getting a lot
more calories just in the rice.
Forget about anything
else that you're eating.
And I don't know how many
of you, but you have sushi,
you're so full, and
then like a half hour
later, you're starving
and you have no idea why.
And a lot of times that's
because-- forget about the sake
bombs for a second--
because a lot of times it's
because you're
totally dehydrated.
And that's because of the salt
and the sugar in the rice.
So that's your first problem.
And also, dehydration, the
symptoms of dehydration
mimics hunger.
So if you're ever really
hungry and that happens,
have a big glass of water.
Wait 15 minutes.
You're probably not
going to be hungry again,
because your body was
probably just thirsty instead
of being hungry.
But back to sushi anyway.
Start with a small
something-- edamame,
a salad with
dressing on the side.
Try hand rolls if you can,
because again, the rice
seems to be a big culprit
of why you're not hungry
and why it's not so filling and
why it has so many calories.
Just one or two rolls could have
over 1,000 calories to them.
So it's a big part of your
day, and it's not as healthy
as you originally
thought it was.
You can try something
like chicken teriyaki
or any of those dishes,
which are a nice alternative.
And try to share.
I mean, most of the when
you go out for sushi,
there's more than one of you.
Get rolls that you like,
have a little bit of them,
and then get something
on the side that's
a little bit healthier.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: This is one
of my favorite questions,
and it comes up in my
office all the time.
Ilyse, should I cut out gluten?
Do you have a
gluten sensitivity?
Do have celiac?
No.
My friend just told me I should
cut out gluten, or whatever.
It's never from a doctor
or a registered dietitian.
My friend said this.
My aunt said this.
My sister said this.
My cousin said that.
So that's something that comes
up in my office constantly.
And I'm not discounting
that some people do have
a real sensitivity to gluten.
And I totally respect
and honor that.
But I think sometimes
people just cut out gluten
because they think
it's the thing to do.
Everybody else is doing it.
It's a fad.
HALLIE RICH: New Atkins diet.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right, exactly.
And sometimes it actually
messes you up, to be honest.
So gluten is a
specific protein found
in wheat, rye, and barley.
If you want to cut
out carbs or go
low carb, which is actually
the type of lifestyle I live,
that's fine.
Do that.
But if you're going
to cut out gluten,
it actually goes
way beyond that.
Gluten is found in instant
coffee, grain alcohol,
soy sauce, mustards, dressings.
And I think a lot of
people, they say to me,
oh, well, I'm eating so healthy.
I had gluten-free
pretzels as a snack.
Well, a gluten-free
pretzel is still a pretzel,
and a gluten-free cookie
is still a cookie.
And they still have calories
and they still have fat.
And believe it or
not, actually, when
they make these gluten-free
products, because there's
no gluten in it,
they have to fill it
with fillers and tapioca flour.
So again, gluten-free
pretzels, gluten-free bread,
if you need it, fine.
But just doing it
to do it, sometimes
people actually end
up gaining weight,
because they're doing it wrong.
And if you're going to go strict
gluten-free, which, again,
is fine if it's
indicated, I wouldn't
recommend using many
of those products,
because there's fillers.
It's more fat.
There's no fiber, so you're
not going to feel that full.
HALLIE RICH: And
some things claim
to be gluten free
that were always
gluten free to begin with.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
HALLIE RICH: So it's
not necessarily a sign
that it's better
than an alternative.
It just might have
always been gluten-free.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
Exactly.
Anyone here cut out
gluten because they
hear it's the thing to do or
they feel like it's trendy?
OK, good, no.
That makes me so happy to hear.
I eat gluten.
I eat dairy.
I tell people that all the time.
And the next thing is dairy.
And again, if you have a
legit medical condition,
or some people say,
you know what, Ilyse,
dairy just really bloats me.
I just don't feel
good with dairy.
Then don't eat it.
But to cut out dairy
just because you
think it's going to help you
lose weight doesn't work.
I eat dairy.
I eat yogurt.
I eat cheese.
I eat all that stuff
on a daily basis.
So eliminating dairy alone
won't help you move the scale.
And dairy has tons of benefits.
It contains vitamins
and minerals
like calcium,
vitamin D, protein.
It obviously supports
strong bones.
And it has the
protein, which helps
to prevent you overeating.
I mean, my biggest thing, I'm
like, I love Greek yogurt.
It has 18 to 20 grams
of protein in it.
It's a great afternoon snack.
It's a great breakfast.
So I'm all about
gluten and dairy.
And like I said, without
a medical indication,
there's really no
reason to cut it out.
Cleanses-- so
everybody is always
looking for that
thing that's going
to help them drop five pounds
or clean up their diet.
But to be honest,
they don't work.
You get hungry.
You get cranky.
Yes, you'll lose a
couple of pounds,
but then the second you
start eating normally,
which 99.99% of people
have to start doing,
you'll gain the weight back.
HALLIE RICH: And maybe more so.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: And
maybe more so sometimes.
Your body already is
doing the cleanse.
I think a lot of
people misunderstand.
We have our liver, our
kidneys, our digestive system,
which are all natural filters.
Some people are
like, well, I just
want to clean out all
the toxins in my body.
You can do that
in a healthy way.
Don't drink alcohol.
Don't eat processed foods.
Cut out artificial sweeteners.
That's a huge one,
including Truvia and stevia,
which we'll get too later.
Cut out the refined carbs.
Cut out the white stuff.
Definitely exercise.
And focus on fruits,
vegetables, and clean protein.
So I think the cleanses can
be expensive and kind of not
necessary.
HALLIE RICH: Protein bars-- so
a lot of us are really busy.
We grab protein bars, whether
before the gym, after the gym.
We're traveling.
We don't have enough
time, running to meetings.
We eat protein bars.
But you know, they're
not a meal replacement.
So once in a while, if it's
something you want to have,
you just need the nourishment,
you're running around,
it's fine.
But don't keep looking at
them as meal replacements.
A lot of times there's
a lot more fat and sugar
than you would.
You're missing a
lot of the nutrients
that you would be getting
just from the actual food that
has the actual protein in it.
They're made with some
soy protein isolates,
which aren't always
exactly the best thing
to be having as well.
And they're just-- there
are many bars out there that
are marketed as protein bars
that you would be better off
having a Snickers.
You know, Snickers actually
has real peanuts in it.
It has real chocolate.
There's not a lot of chemicals.
And you'd be surprised by
looking at the nutrition facts.
If you took a Snickers and
you took a protein bar,
if we showed you
the back of them,
you'd be surprised to
know that you'd probably
pick the Snickers bar as the one
as being the protein bar, not
the actual protein
bar, depending
upon the brand out there.
Brands that we like-- Think
Thin, Quest, Pure Protein,
they tend to have a lot of
protein, a little sugar,
a little fat, little calories.
So not that we're
plugging anybody,
but we like those,
because people always
ask us which brands we do like.
But you really want to watch
the ratio there and make sure
that you're actually
getting a lot of protein
and less of everything else.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: OK, good.
All right, organic.
Who in this room tries to
buy organic, even if it's
for some of some things?
All good.
Perfect.
So we're here to tell you there
are certain things you should
or try to buy organic,
and then there
are some things you don't
have to stress out about,
one of them being bananas,
which actually happens to not
be on here, but a lot of
people say, oh my God,
I bought organic bananas.
I'm like, you just
wasted your money.
Anything with a thick skin,
you don't need to buy organic.
But there are plenty of things
that the Environmental Working
Group, which is the EWG,
which this changes every year,
recommends that you buy organic.
So huge ones-- the dirty dozen--
apples, celery, cherries,
cucumbers, which I actually
just recently switched
to organic cucumbers.
They taste different.
Grapes, nectarines,
peaches, snap peas, spinach,
strawberries, sweet bell
peppers, and tomatoes.
Those are the ones that they
say have the highest pesticide
residue, and you should
aim to buy organic.
Now, the cleanest
fruits and veggies
that you don't have to waste
your money on-- asparagus,
avocado, cabbage, cantaloupe,
cauliflower, eggplant,
grapefruit, honeydew,
mangoes, kiwi, onions, papaya,
pineapple, sweet
corn, and sweet peas.
And if you don't have
access to organic,
look for local produce.
It's easy to buy, actually,
frozen organic fruits
and vegetables in
the supermarket,
and those are just
as good for you.
Some things that are
not necessary to buy
organic-- breads, cookies.
Again, an organic cookie
is still a cookie.
And you want to look for
the USDA organic label
for 100% organic products.
HALLIE RICH: So alcohol--
[LAUGHTER]
--we know that you guys
are going to drink,
and we're here to show
you how to do that
in the healthiest way possible.
Alcohol has no nutritional
value whatsoever,
so don't think just because
you're having a pina colada,
for example, and it's made
with coconuts, that you're
going to get something from it.
Doesn't really work that way.
Apple pie doesn't really give
you the benefits of the apples.
So kind of pick your alcohols
intelligently, if you would,
if you're trying to
watch your weight
and that's important to you.
A six-ounce glass of wine
only has 150 calories.
The same size pina colada has
three times, or 450 calories.
So again, if you're sitting on
the beach and your feet are up
and you're on a lounge
chair at the pool,
we're not going to tell you
not to have your pina colada.
But maybe don't have a bunch,
and don't have them every day.
Just kind of be careful,
especially of the things
with the sugar around the rim
or the little pretty umbrellas
in them.
They're so pretty
because they're masking
what's really inside of them.
If you're going
to have beer, try
to stick with your
ultra-low-carb beer.
Mixed drinks, try to
stick with one mixer.
Best mixers would be a seltzer.
Try to avoid the
fruit juice, which
we'll get into in a
second about fruit juices.
If you don't like your alcohol
with it, just have a splash.
It will really cut down
on calories and sugar,
and you'll probably enjoy
the drink a little bit more.
And you'll need
less because you're
having more of the alcohol.
And ounce for ounce, the
stronger the alcohol,
the more calories
there are in there.
So you probably hopefully
don't need as much,
because the alcohol is stronger.
But just be mindful of that.
So that's the deal with alcohol.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: All right.
And did you talk
about the proof?
HALLIE RICH: Yeah.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: OK.
All right, breakfast.
HALLIE RICH: Cereal-- so I
think we've all kind of been
ingrained that Saturday
morning or what
used to be Saturday
morning cartoon cereals are
the things that should
definitely be avoided.
You know, they're very colorful.
They're full of sugar,
artificial colors, sweeteners,
flavors, and dyes.
But what's so interesting
is that the things that
are marketed towards
you are actually,
I don't want to use
the word way worse,
but have a lot more sugar and
a lot more calories and a lot
more dyes than you would think.
Out of all these
cereals up there,
would someone tell me
which ones they would avoid
or which ones they
would lean to,
or which ones they actually eat?
Anyone know which
has the most sugar?
All right, well, Raisin
Bran has the most sugar.
It has 18 grams of sugar.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: I know.
I love the confusion
in the room.
HALLIE RICH: Followed
by Smart Start and Go
Lean, which have 14 grams
and 13 grams, respectively.
Your Cinnamon Toast Crunch,
your Mini Wheats, and your Fruit
Loops, out of everything
on the screen,
has your least amount of sugar.
So it's really
interesting that you'll
be walking down the
supermarket and see someone
who has Fruit
Loops in their cart
and you have the Smart Start,
you're like, ooh, look at me.
I'm so awesome.
But not really.
You have to really be careful
and look at the back of things,
because just because they're
not marketed towards kids--
and there's a cereal that
I used to eat all the time,
and when we were doing
this, I looked at the back
and I was shocked to see that
it had food dyes in it, that it
had a lot of
artificial chemicals.
And there it was.
I thought it was
good because I looked
at the nutritional
content, but I didn't
look at the other ingredients.
So it's really important to kind
of look at what you're taking,
because just because they're
not geared towards kids--
a lot of these companies
have been responsible
and they kind of reacted
to the outrage of parents
for what they were
giving their children.
But because there wasn't
outrage of what they were giving
themselves, they kind of
snuck some things in there,
and they didn't really
react that way to it.
So just be mindful
of what's there.
Again, we're not saying
don't eat cereal,
and if you love one of those
brands, keep eating it.
Just be mindful how much
sugar, how many calories,
or the other things
that you're eating
throughout the rest of the
day, because it might not
be the healthy start that
you think you're getting.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
Right.
Raisin Bran is full of
sugar-- full of sugar.
OK, anyway, artificial
sweeteners, another one
of my favorite topics.
Who wants to admit that
they use something?
Pink, yellow, blue,
Truvia, stevia?
Nobody in here uses
artificial sweeteners?
A handful-- a handful.
Drinks diet soda?
All righty.
So I always tell people I
used to be a Diet Coke addict.
I used to be a Diet
Coke addict, and then
when I decided to
have children, I
cut it out because I just
didn't want it in my body.
And not on purpose, but
I lost five pounds just
from cutting out
artificial sweeteners.
So I know a lot of people
are kind of getting away
from these colorful packets.
They're still out there.
My husband uses Splenda.
So it just is what it is.
But we're just here
to educate you.
So Sweet and Low is 300
to 500 times sweeter
than regular sugar.
Equal is 200 times sweeter, and
Splenda is 600 times sweeter
than regular sugar.
Our point is actually intake
of artificial sweeteners
can actually affect
your body's ability
to regulate itself and
regulate its metabolism
and regulate its weight.
Like I said, I cut it out when
I was trying to get pregnant
and I lost five pounds.
Then you actually, when
you have a lot of these,
you crave more sweet.
And then even sometimes
fruits and vegetables
like strawberries, blueberries,
don't even taste sweet to you
anymore.
Or I have clients who put
Splenda in their Greek yogurt
to make it taste better.
And there are
numerous studies that
have been published
recently that it actually is
linked to an increase in BMI.
And a lot of people say to
me, well, but I use Truvia,
I have stevia.
I tell people, if it's
powdered and in a packet,
it's still processed.
So if you need
something, either just do
one teaspoon of regular
sugar, sugar in the raw,
or the best kind of
noncalorie sweetener
is stevia leaf extract,
which is a dropper.
So you can buy that at like
a Whole Foods or Mrs. Green's
or something like that.
And then kind of
going along with this,
where is sugar hidden?
Now, I eat foods that
have sugar in them.
I think it's unrealistic
to completely eliminate it.
But I know a lot
of people are just
trying to be more and
more conscious about it.
So we're just kind of
here to empower you.
And no longer do they just
list sugar on the label.
They've gotten really
smart to hide it in places
where we wouldn't know.
So you want to always look
at the sugar content in terms
of grams, and then you
want to read the label
and look out for added sugars.
Anything that ends in ose--
dextrose, fructose, lactose--
anything that has a syrup or a
juice, corn syrup, cane juice.
And even if it says organic
cane sugar is still sugar,
agave is still
sugar-- maple syrup.
And then less obvious
names-- dextrin honey,
hydrogenated starch,
molasses, sorghum.
And again, we're
just saying if you're
somebody who's conscious about
your sugar intake for the day,
this is just other ways
to look out for it,
because it's no longer just
called sugar on the label.
All right, so there are
plenty of foods out there
that get kind of
this health halo
effect, which is a real term.
What are the foods that we
think are healthy, but aren't?
So the first one is dried fruit.
And I think anybody in here
think dried fruit is healthy,
or they like it or-- so
actually a bunch of you.
A ton of you.
The thing with dried fruit,
raisins or any other kind
of dried fruit, is
that actually it's
totally depleted in nutrients.
And it's less filling.
If you think about it, they've
taken the water out of it,
so it's not going to be filling.
And it's actually loaded
with calories and sugar.
Even if it says no sugar added,
because there's no water in it,
it's very concentrated.
Same with veggie pasta
and veggie chips.
I say a veggie chip is still
a chip, and veggie pasta,
it basically just has
powdered spinach powder in it.
You're much better off having
pasta, having whole wheat
pasta, and pairing it
with real vegetables,
and you'll get a
much better effect.
And the veggie chips, again,
do they serve a purpose?
Do I have them in
my house sometimes
because I have two young kids?
Absolutely.
But you just have to know,
it's still kind of a chip.
Yes, it has less fat.
But obviously, you're better
off eating real vegetables.
HALLIE RICH: Yeah, go
with the chip you want.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
Right, right, exactly.
HALLIE RICH: Because
the veggie chip
is not necessarily healthier.
Fruit juice is kind of deceiving
because it has tons of sugar.
Just kind of giving another
analogy, Mott's apple juice
has 28 grams of sugar
for an eight-ounce cup.
Pepsi has the exact
same amount of sugar.
So you might think
that you're drinking
something that's healthier.
Again, I'm not advocating
to drink soda necessarily,
but just don't think you're
making the smarter choice
necessarily by
having fruit juice,
whether it's by itself, in your
alcohol, or whatever it is.
Fruit juice can be very
deceivingly high in sugar.
Same with trail mix.
Even though it's delicious,
it's nuts, it's got a lot of fat
in there.
And a lot of times
with your trail mix,
you're having little
crackers, there's chocolate,
there's M&Ms, which,
again, I love.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: And
the dried fruit.
HALLIE RICH: Right, dried fruit.
So you just have to be careful.
With trail mix, the
most important thing
is serving size.
Don't go in there and
get a huge heaping of it.
Just have a little
bit of a taste
and enjoy it, and just
use it for what it is.
And when it comes
to buzzwords, this
is something that's
really interesting.
Whether it's the
word natural, which
has zero meaning when
it comes to the FDA
and what they assign to have
natural, it has no definition.
So what you think of natural
and what you think of natural,
you're both right and
you're both wrong,
because it doesn't
mean anything.
So you might be picking
something up and thinking,
oh, I'm getting
something better,
whether it's because more
money, whether you think
it's just a healthier thing.
But don't fall into that trap.
Same with the things like
skinny, smart, from the Earth.
Any of those kinds of terms
are just marketing terms.
I mean, you guys deal
with them all the time.
They're just things
that they think
will excite you and
get you to buy them.
And they're normally right,
because people think, well,
if they're saying that on
a box or a label or a can,
it must mean something,
and it doesn't.
So again, if you like it
and you want to buy it,
do it, but don't think you're
getting some added benefit.
You might be, but you
also might not be.
It's 50-50,
depending upon what's
on the back of the label.
Something else, like
honey wheat pretzels
versus regular pretzels,
actually the regular pretzels
have less sugar, less fat,
than the honey wheat pretzels.
So it's very interesting that
if you just take two seconds,
turn two things over,
you'll be able to see.
And don't be afraid of
that nutrition label.
It's all really laid out
there for you very carefully.
And it's very easy
to compare things.
So that's kind of the
deal with buzzwords.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
As we were writing the
book, the two of us
literally went to
the supermarket
and looked at Baked
Lays versus Regular Lays
and reduced fat versus this.
HALLIE RICH: And sometimes
that makes a difference.
There are cookies that go
from 10 grams of fat to five
grams of fat, because reduced
fat has to be cut in half.
But if it's two grams
to one gram, what
are you getting there?
You're getting more fillers.
You're getting more binders.
You're getting more chemicals.
I mean, whether it's
fruit or it's cookies,
when you take something out, you
have to put something back in.
Otherwise it's not gonna
have the same substance.
It's not going to taste
the same in your mouth.
The mouth feel is
going to be different.
So what are they
putting it back in for?
And maybe that
doesn't matter to you.
Maybe it does.
And that's kind of what we say.
We're not here to tell
you which one to have.
Just make the right decision
on what your priorities are so
that you can make
the right decisions
for your lifestyle and
your health lifestyle
and what matters to you.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: OK, cool.
All right, I'm going to give
the five minute warning,
If anybody has
questions, you could
start lining up
at the microphone
as we kind of wrap up.
HALLIE RICH: Jet lag
is just something
when we talk to a lot
of corporate people,
they seem to be very interested
in, because you're always
traveling, whether it's for
you guys to the West Coast
or different meetings
across the oceans.
But how do you deal with it?
And instead of feeling sluggish
and out of sorts and fatigued,
so one thing would be melatonin.
You want to start
a few days before.
There's plenty of
foods where you
can see, like oatmeal,
bananas, oranges,
that you can get them from.
They also come in
supplement form.
Pycnogenol is something you
might not be as familiar with.
It actually comes from
the bark of pine trees.
There was a study that says
if you have 50 grams two days
before and continuing
through five days
after, it'll help not only
with some symptoms of jet lag,
but also with your
immunity, which is always
important because
when you're on a plane
or you're in the airport
and everyone's sneezing
and coughing around
you, and you're
taking a trip with 100 people on
the plane and all their germs,
something you kind of don't
want to take home with you.
Same with the
vitamins B, C, and E.
Those are really
important for helping
to support your immunity.
And again, you can get those
in chocolates, blueberries,
grapes, oranges.
If you're already
taking a multi-vitamin,
it's something you're
getting in there already,
so you may not need any extra.
But it's really important
for both your jet lag
and for your immunity.
You don't want to be
feeling under the weather
or out of sorts when you're
giving an important talk
or listening to us, or just
on a vacation with friends
and family.
You want to enjoy yourself.
You paid a lot for
that trip and you don't
want to worry about jet lag.
And also, just
drink tons of water.
Try to avoid alcohol.
Sleep when you
should be sleeping.
Eat when you should
be eating, and that
will help you with jet lag.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: All
right, vitawoman.
HALLIE RICH: So
the question I get
asked the most is, do I really
need to be taking any vitamins?
I eat really well.
And it seems like you guys do
eat pretty well, considering
how you've answered some
of the questions so far.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Plus
the cafeteria's awesome.
HALLIE RICH: Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
But what's really interesting
is that food today
isn't what food used to be.
And there's a really interesting
statistic from the USDA
that you would have to have
seven cups of spinach today
to get the same
nutritional content you
would have had to get from one
cup of spinach in the 1960s.
And again, that's not us
saying don't have spinach.
It's just saying
soil is overfarmed.
It's depleted.
There's chemicals.
There's lots of different
things in the soil that
just make even a
healthy food not as
healthy as it used to be.
And so you would really
need to overcompensate
for what your
grandparents used to have
and how they used to eat.
Also, a lot of times food
used to be from farm to table.
Now you're getting
fruits and vegetables
from Central America.
They pick them
before they're ripe.
They sit on your
shelves, and it's just
a different kind of food.
So even if you're
eating really well,
you're not necessarily getting
all the nutritional benefits
that you would be, even
if you eat a perfect diet.
Then we all know that we
all don't eat perfect diets.
We're human.
We're both human.
You have different types
of foods during the day.
Some days are better
than other days.
And a vitamin really
is an insurance policy.
And a vitamin is
part of a category
of products called supplements.
And really what
you want to do is
you want to supplement your
diet with proper products.
So you don't want to--
it's not a license
to eat whatever you want.
And anyone who tells you that,
if they're in my industry,
they're embarrassing
my industry.
That's not who we are.
We're about adding
to what you're
doing so that you're
getting the most out
of everything, because
your body really
needs the right vitamins,
minerals, and antioxidants
to function properly.
And you want to make sure you're
getting that, hopefully mostly
from food, but whatever
you can't get from food--
you have car insurance,
you have life insurance,
you have health insurance.
Think of vitamins as
your body's insurance.
I would always say start
with a multi-vitamin.
It's your great basic
foundation program.
It has enough of your vitamins
and minerals in there.
Something to be
mindful of, though,
make sure your multi has both
vitamins and minerals in there.
Are a lot of times they'll
call themselves a multi,
but you won't see calcium.
You won't see
magnesium in there.
So just make sure that
you're getting both.
If you want to add
other things on there,
you can look at probiotics.
You can look at omegas,
things with CoQ10.
But those are just the
kind of different things
that you can add onto it.
But I would always
start with a multi.
And even though it's
summer, one thing
I know Ilyse stresses
a lot is vitamin D.
Make sure it has a good
amount of vitamin D in there.
Vitamin D is actually a hormone.
And whether it's the sun
that you need to produce it,
it's very hard to get from food.
So we say it's
trendy for a reason.
Vitamin D is actually a
very important nutrient.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
And 77% of Americans
are vitamin D deficient.
So it's really important
to get your levels checked
from your doctor.
But it can't hurt to
have at least 1,000 IUs
of vitamin D in your--
HALLIE RICH: Right.
I mean, a lot of things, for
women especially, calcium,
but you would be
surprised, if you all
Google it, to see what
you're deficient in.
There are so many--
the majority of people,
even though they
think they eat well,
are actually deficient
in many nutrients.
So it's kind of an
interesting statistic.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Yeah.
OK, cool.
So wrapping up.
So steps for optimal success.
Don't skip meals.
This is huge.
Plan ahead if you
have a busy day.
But it's always important.
I just got interviewed-- should
I eat breakfast every day?
I'm a huge believer
in starting your day
with a healthy breakfast
and then eating
every three to four hours.
I get it.
I'm a working mom.
I'm busy.
I grab something as I'm
running out the door.
I kind of pack my
lunch for the day,
because I don't want to
be stuck without food.
Luckily, you guys, again,
have a great cafeteria
where it's at your fingertips.
But if you're out and
about and traveling,
it's really important
to plan ahead.
You want to fuel your body
with high-quality food
as best you can.
Eat every three to
four to five hours.
Stay hydrated-- huge.
As you can see I've been
drinking this water as we go.
Plan ahead if you
have a busy day.
Aim for seven to eight
hours of sleep per night.
I think people
also underestimate
the power of sleep.
A big thing, maybe you guys
know, maybe you don't, they
even say turn off your devices
at least a half hour before
you go to bed, because that
light is very stimulating.
I even throw a T-shirt
on my cable box,
because even the light
from the cable box
is too stimulating for me.
But seven to eight
hours per night-- A,
obviously you function
better the next day.
But it also affects your
weight, how much sleep,
because if you
don't sleep enough,
it increases cortisol levels
in the body and kind of just
holds on to that weight
you're trying to lose.
Be active.
If you're not a gym
person, that's OK.
Aim for 10,000 steps
per day, whether you
have a Fitbit or
certain phones actually
track your steps,
which is awesome.
Check in with your step counter
daily and aim for 10,000 steps.
Don't ignore the power of
proper supplementation.
We say everything
in moderation, which
is what we totally
preach in our book
and what I preach
in my practice.
And honor and respect your body.
So thank you, and
you can follow us
on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram.
And we'll start
taking questions.
And maybe as people
ask questions,
more questions will
kind of come up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a comment and a question.
The comment, I was not going
to make it in the beginning,
but you mentioned, buzzwords,
and I cannot hold myself.
You talk about chemicals,
like chemicals are everything.
The salt that you add, even
it's just pure chemical.
I believe that you should use
the word like industrially
synthesized as opposed
to naturally synthesized
chemicals, because every
time, some people, it's like,
oh, you add chemicals to it.
It's like, yeah.
Anything that I add, even just
pure water, is a chemical.
So we should also try
to avoid that buzzword
that is against the standard
process of preparing
your food, which is you're
just combining chemicals
to prepare something.
So that was the comment.
And then the question is,
let me know if I'm incorrect,
if I'm not right.
You said in the
beginning that you
made the book in order for
us to make better decisions.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So two questions then.
What is your opinion and what
he's the things that we should
do against, like, for example,
the sugar industry that
is trying to hide the
addition of sugars into milk?
How can we make decisions if
we don't have the information
to make those decisions?
And also, the humans are
essentially bad decision
makers.
So what is your stand
like imposing some kind
of regulatory better decision
making process so that people
cannot make bad decisions
because they don't have
the possibility to
make bad decisions?
And I'm talking
about, for example,
reducing the amount
of sugars that
can be sold in schools
or food programs
for children, like the fact
that they can buy a bag of chips
more than a plate of spinach.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
HALLIE RICH: I think it's a lot
bigger conversation than just
us.
I mean, for example,
cheap food is more
affordable than healthier food.
So if you're
talking about people
who are on limited
incomes, limited budgets,
they may not have, even though
we may say buy organic this
or stay away from
chemicals or diet soda,
if that's on sale
at the store for $1
and everything
else is four times
that, people have
budgetary limits of things
that they can do.
So until you kind of start
going from a government level
that healthier things
become more affordable,
it's going to be hard
to really dictate that,
because many people then really
go into food deserts and things
like that would be
a lot harder to do.
I agree with you about
the chemical thing.
I think a lot of
things get-- and maybe
that is something we need
to be a little bit more
mindful of, about chemicals.
A lot of times, even in my
industry, they'll be like,
well, is this organic vitamins?
Well, not everything
organic is good.
Not everything
organic is better.
So I think it is
something that we
do have to be mindful of
in the terms that we use.
But in terms of people
making decisions and things
with sugar, unless
companies are not
abiding by the laws in which
they're regulated by already,
all the sugars, even if
they're trying to hide things
in sugars, and hopefully
we've given you some terms
to look at now and
the other ingredients,
but it all has to
be listed on there.
If not, the company is
doing something illegal.
And yes, there are
people who do that,
but I'm sure in every industry.
I'm sure you guys have
competitors in whatever space
you guys are in within this
company that there are people
who play by the rules and
there are people who don't.
There's people who skirt the
rules and there are people who
don't.
But I do think
that, unfortunately,
regulating what people can eat
and making healthier decisions
is not just as easy
as that, because
of just the cost of what
that would mean to people
and how they live and how
they budget their lives
and the salaries that they make.
And not everyone can afford
with the way that things are.
I mean, you're subsidizing corn.
You're subsidizing
all these things
that make chips a lot more
cheaper and affordable
than it does your organic
celery or whatever it is.
It's just not affordable
to a lot of people,
I don't think it's as cut
and dry as just enforcing
those decisions on people.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
I think it's hard.
They're changing the food label.
I can't remember when it
comes out, but they are--
HALLIE RICH: In two years.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
Right-- changing it
to show where added sugars
are, versus just giving you
the basic sugar grams.
I think they have to
include added sugars
and stuff like that.
HALLIE RICH: Right.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: But
I think it also--
I speak at a lot of
schools, and sometimes I'm
appalled that they still have
white bread to these kids.
These kids, or my day
camp where my kids go,
two years ago they finally
stopped serving white bread
and they only gave whole
wheat bread as an option.
So I think it kind
of starts smaller
at schools and companies.
But I don't know.
I can't even speak
about government.
But I think it gets really
tricky on a bigger level.
So I think just
at smaller levels
within your community,
that's where it kind of has
to start for change.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Sure.
Thank you.
You want to go, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for coming.
Can you guys hear me?
I'm so short.
Thanks so much for coming.
A lot of great
information here, and I'm
excited to read the book.
Two foods that I always get
conflicting information on
are avocado and bananas.
So I'd love to know
a little bit more
about those from a health
side and whether or not
we should even be avoiding them,
or just a little more on those.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: That's
a great question.
Avocados are awesome for you.
So even though avocados
have a lot of calories
and have a lot of fat,
avocados are the good fat,
which I'm sure you've also
heard about, with nuts and nut
butters.
Avocados are full with
mono unsaturated fats.
Those are the healthy fats.
That's what protects your heart
and kind of prevents heart
disease.
So I wouldn't eat a
whole avocado a day.
But anywhere between a quarter
to half of an avocado per day
if you're watching your
weight is fair game.
Also because it does
have that good fat,
it's going to keep
you more satisfied
and it's going to keep you full
and prevent overeating, prevent
that, oh, I need
chips with my lunch,
where maybe you just had
a sandwich with turkey
and avocado, and then
you'll feel more satisfied.
Bananas get a bad rap.
Are you talking about from
like a sugar standpoint?
AUDIENCE: Just an
everything standpoint.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: So I
would say if somebody
is athletic and works out
a lot, bananas are great.
They're filled with potassium.
I think they're a great
pre-workout snack, either alone
or with some almond
butter or peanut
butter, something like that.
They are slightly more sugar
than some other fruits,
than like an apple or berries.
But bananas can be great
because they're portable.
And again, if
you're somebody who
exercises a couple
times per week,
you shouldn't have a
problem, as long you
stick to one banana per day.
HALLIE RICH: And it's also,
what are you comparing it to?
Is it a banana and
a bag of chips?
Is it a banana and nothing?
So I think you have
to, again, look
at the entirety of the picture.
You can't just look at
something in isolation
and say, oh, bananas are
bad, because if you're
talking about a banana versus
a Dunkin' Donut or something--
again, it was just
National Donut Day,
and we all had to avoid them.
But you have to kind of, really,
what are you comparing it to,
because even though it
might have more sugar,
it's probably better than
nine of the other things
you're going to pick.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
HALLIE RICH: So you
just have to look
at it in the entirety
of your day or your week
and not just at that one
solitary defining moment.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: But
I would say if you're
looking for one of the best
fruits, blueberries are great.
They're filled with fiber.
They're filling.
They're filled
with antioxidants.
But they're not exactly the
easiest, most portable snack.
Bananas are great because you
can grab it on the go or--
HALLIE RICH: Throw
it in your purse.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Throw it in
your purse, something like that.
So again, if you
exercise or work out,
I say go for it, because
it's got the potassium.
And they even say,
this is actually
interesting about
bananas, I'm going
to misspeak-- the
riper it is, where
it's more green than not--
is that ripe or unripe?
Unripe.
The more unripe it is, actually
it has resistant starch,
so it's less likely to
affect your blood sugar.
So actually, if you're watching
your weight or concerned,
you're better off
buying it more green,
because your body is less
affected by the starch
and sugar in the body, which is
something I learned recently.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
Great news about
the avocados for me.
In the slides it said stick with
low fat, referring to dairy,
and I was wondering if you
guys could comment more
on whole fat versus nonfat
versus halfway in between,
'cause you said when
you take something out,
you have to put it back in.
So I was wondering if
there's a rule of thumb
or if it varies by
product, things like that.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: I got this.
So I get this
question all the time.
I'm a big believer
in, not whole milk,
but not skim, the low fat
in the middle, the 2%.
In terms of products,
like reduced-fat cookies,
yes, they end up
adding sugar and stuff
like that to replace the fat.
But in terms of dairy, or
if you like Greek yogurt,
get the 2% Greek yogurt.
It's going to feel more filling,
and there's not that many more
calories to it.
But again, I don't think you
have to go the whole milk
route, because whole milk
does have saturated fat,
which does clog your arteries.
So I would go the middle of the
road, 2% for dairy-- cheese,
yogurt, milk, that
type of thing.
But again, if you
go out for dinner
and you have fresh mozzarella
cheese, I say go for it.
It's delicious.
But milk, yogurt, on
a day-to-day basis,
get the 2% middle of the road.
So that's what we
mean by low fat.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HALLIE RICH: Just
with the cheese,
we have a question in our
book where we talk exclusively
about cheeses, and we say the
full-fat cheese is actually
going to keep you
more satisfied.
It tastes a lot better.
So just have a
little bit of that
instead of having all
of this no-fat cheese.
First of all, I don't
know if you've ever
tried making like a grilled
cheese sandwich or an omelette
with the no-fat cheese.
It just kind of sits there.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
It's like plastic.
HALLIE RICH: It doesn't
even do anything.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
HALLIE RICH: So just go with
what you like a lot of times,
especially with cheeses,
the whole fat variety.
It's going to taste better and
you're going to enjoy it more,
and you're not
going to be looking
for a lot of other things.
And you'll probably net out
with less calories and less fat
than by eating way more
of the fat-free variety,
or-- obviously the reduced fat
or 2% was a great option too.
But if that's not
available for you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I had two questions.
The first is, why is there so
much competing points of view
on nutrition?
Why is your book the right
way versus other ways?
Why does all this exist?
And the second question is, have
you all evaluated the Google
Microkitchens for good snacks?
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: The what?
Can you say that?
I just couldn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: The Google
Microkitchens,
which are little
snack rooms that we
have here for good snacks.
HALLIE RICH: We haven't, but
we'll gladly do that later.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
We looked briefly.
We didn't have that much
time right before, but after.
HALLIE RICH: I think
what's interesting,
and I don't even know if Ilyse
agrees with me, about nutrition
and about the health
and wellness category
as a whole is that
there's a lot of competing
interests out there.
And I always say, you
have food on one side
who want to believe you can get
everything you need from food.
And then you have the
pharmaceutical industry
who wants to believe
that everything
can be cured by medicine.
And then you have this like
health and wellness movement
in the middle who want
you to eat well and want
you to go to the doctor
when you don't feel well,
but there's other,
more proactive ways
of looking at your health.
And I think a lot of times,
what's interesting with studies
is, who funded them?
Why do they exist?
What is the point behind them?
And a lot of times,
let's say in my industry,
they'll say vitamins
don't cure cancer.
Tell me something I didn't know.
They shouldn't.
They're not supposed to.
Nothing cures cancer.
Chemo doesn't cure cancer.
So I think it's really
interesting to say,
are you trying to
prove something that's
a falsehood to begin with?
What's your motive behind it?
And I think a lot of
times also, are there
double-blind placebo studies?
Are they just looking at a
small percentage of people?
Is it over years?
What information did they
leave out of the study?
A lot of the most
interesting parts
of studies if you're
looking at the research
is what they didn't include,
what they threw away.
Was that because it
didn't prove their point?
Was that because
it wasn't relevant?
Who were their subjects?
Are they people who were
unhealthy to begin with?
Are they just a random
group of people?
A lot of these things
are so-- unfortunately,
a lot of times when the
news reports things,
they just give
you the headlines.
But if you just read three
sentences into the abstract,
you'd get a totally
different view of what
the study was presenting.
And I think that's unfortunately
why there's so much
mixed messaging out
there, because it's
who read through the study
and who just read the headline
and trying to take
it away from that.
And I think that again, because
food has particular interests,
pharmaceutical has
particular interests,
and they're all good.
We all love our drugs
when they make us feel
better when we don't feel well.
We all love our good food, and
we all love our bad food, too.
We're not here to disparage
any of those people.
But a lot of times a lot
of these big companies
fund these studies
and they're trying
to support something that
moves their bottom line
and moves their product.
And I think that unfortunately,
that's not always reported.
And I think that's why there's
so much competing interest.
And I think the reason that
our book has done so well
and why we've gotten so
much positive feedback is
because we're not
here telling you,
eliminate this
whole class of food.
Don't do something.
We're all human.
We all want to enjoy life.
We all want to eat,
and we want to eat
the things we like to eat.
We're not here to kind of
dictate to you how you live
and how you eat and what
you put into your body.
The point is, how do you
make smarter decisions
and get rid of a
lot of that bias
against certain foods,
bananas for example.
Again, it's what
is it compared to?
We kind of want to put things
into perspective for you
and make it part of
a larger discussion,
as opposed to just isolating
things, because when
you isolate anything, it could
be good, bad, or indifferent.
It's just a matter of
it's not how you live.
So I think that's how our
book kind of goes at that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
It'd be cool if you all
could look at the snacks
that we have.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
We definitely will
AUDIENCE: And make
a recommendation.
[LAUGHTER]
HALLIE RICH: Try them all out.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks again for coming.
I just wanted to dig in
on the dairy question
a little bit more.
So what kind of milk packs
the most nutritional punch?
So I have two kids, and the
ultrapasteurized, I found,
is just really expensive water.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
AUDIENCE: So what's the deal,
ultrapasteurized, pasteurized,
homogenized, non-homogenized.
What is the best from a
nutritional standpoint?
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: I would say the
best is-- and I wouldn't get,
and part of what we
speak about, don't
feel like you have to get
wrapped up in all those terms.
AUDIENCE: Totally.
I'm already there.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Trust me, we
all have, or a lot of my clients
have.
Don't stress yourself out.
Go buy for your kids.
Go buy organic, either--
how old are they?
AUDIENCE: 2 and 3.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: 2 and 3.
AUDIENCE: No,
organic is baseline.
HALLIE RICH: Obviously.
I don't think you have
to drive yourself nuts.
Just go buy the organic
2%, or even whole milk
depending on what your
pediatrician recommends
for them at this age.
I don't know their weights
or anything like that.
And don't stress yourself
out about the ultrafiltered--
AUDIENCE: It doesn't matter?
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: No.
Everybody's-- and kind of along
with that question that we just
asked, unfortunately everybody's
looking to make a buck,
and everybody's looking to
get you to buy their product
because they're
different and distinct.
So sometimes don't get
yourself stressed out about it.
And sometimes go for
the most simple thing.
AUDIENCE: So they're
kind of created equal
from a pasteurization,
ultra versus regular.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
To be honest, I don't
know in detail about that.
I'm happy to look it up
and you can e-mail me,
or I can grab your
e-mail at the end,
because now you
have me thinking.
But I would say, to me, basic
organic whole milk or 2%
milk is, why not?
AUDIENCE: I've just
done so much research
and I know there's
so much focus on it
now, so I just wanted to
hear your point of view.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
But now I'm going
to go look it up.
AUDIENCE: It's an
interesting topic.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
Yeah, absolutely.
Perfect.
AUDIENCE: I'll let you go.
She was waiting.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm sorry.
I'm short too.
I was actually recently
advised by a doctor
for a medical condition to go
on a low-sodium diet, which
is the worst thing
in the world for me,
because I put salt
on salt, literally.
And everything is just
really bland to me now.
I found Mrs. Dash
and New Salt to use,
like when I'm cooking
chicken or fish or something.
But it's still super bland.
And I'm shocked by how many
condiments and dressings have--
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Tons.
HALLIE RICH:
Everything has salt.
AUDIENCE: That's where I
used to get most of my salt,
and it really-- I used
to live on ketchup.
Now I don't even use it.
Do you have advice
on snacks and ways
to dress your food so
that it has a little bit
more flavor and taste, because
I just don't enjoy [INAUDIBLE].
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Well, I
would say for cooking,
garlic, cooking
with fresh garlic,
I feel like really helps
enhance the flavor,
and whether you use olive oil
or coconut oil or something
like that, for sure.
And trying out those spices,
but also different spices,
like paprika and cayenne, and
garlic powder, onion powder,
the ones that don't
have sodium in it.
But I would just try
experimenting with spices,
or even just sauteing an onion.
And then for snacks,
unfortunately you
have to be really
careful, but you
could do an apple with
unsalted almond butter,
or an apple with unsalted
peanut butter, or unsalted nuts.
AUDIENCE: What about more
on-the-go type snacks,
because like you, I have kids.
I'm always on the go.
And they're always going
for the pretzels and things,
and I'm just starving because
I can't just cut fresh fruit
and bring it around
with me everywhere.
It's not easy.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Banana, apple.
But a lot of companies make
the unsalted to-go nuts,
so you could put
that in your bag.
Even some-- I don't know
off the top of my head.
I'd actually have to look.
Some of the Kind
bars, but I'd have
to look, to be honest with you,
on the label on the sodium.
But some of those things.
But even now, they make peanut
butter and almond butter
packets, which is awesome.
So I know you're not going
carry around a jar with you,
but you could carry around that
and an apple and-- it's great,
though.
I picked some up at
a seminar yesterday.
HALLIE RICH: Low sodium's hard.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: It is hard.
HALLIE RICH: Sodium's
like the new--
AUDIENCE: It's the worst.
HALLIE RICH: Yeah, because when
we talk about taking things
out and putting things
back in, a lot of times
they're putting in salt,
because it's the great flavor
masker, which is why nothing
tastes good to you anymore,
because there's no salt.
AUDIENCE: Retraining my mouth.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: No, that's
exactly what you have to do.
HALLIE RICH: And it's
going to take time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thanks for coming over
for us and educating us.
Two questions.
I missed the first
part of the session,
so I don't know if you answered
that question, should we really
scoop out our bagel, or
if it's part of the book.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: We'll
answer it in a second.
What's your second question?
AUDIENCE: And the second
question, how bad is honey,
because I saw one
of your slides,
stay away from sugar and honey.
But I don't use sugar at all.
But I kind of use honey
as a supplement sometimes.
Is honey as bad as sugar?
ILYSE SCHAPIRO:
So honey is sugar,
and we just want you
to recognize that.
Now if you're using one teaspoon
or two teaspoons of honey
per day, that is absolutely
fine, unless you have diabetes.
So don't stress about that.
If you're using globs
of honey because you
think it's healthier for
you, then we just say,
just watch out.
And kind of a cool little
tidbit, some people
use local honey to
prevent allergies.
Is that what you do?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's
what I was told.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Yeah.
People swear by it
instead of taking
Claritin or allergy medicine.
So again, as long as
you're sticking to one
to two teaspoons
per day, that's fine
as long as your sugar intake
for the rest of the day is low.
You want to talk
about the bagel scoop?
HALLIE RICH: Sure.
Yeah, I mean we
just say if you're
trying to watch your
weight, scooping bagels is
a great thing.
We just said, be careful
not to eat the scooping when
you take it out, and not
to overfill your bagel.
And if you don't want
to scoop, try things
like flagels, deli
thins, just half a bagel.
Those can be great options
to not scooping your bagel
if you don't want to.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: And feel free to
take some of the Rainbow Bagels
home.
There's plenty.
HALLIE RICH: Especially
those of you who have kids.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Yeah.
Take some home.
AUDIENCE: Going back
to the avocados,
something I read
about is there's
a difference between
omega-3 and omega-6,
and people say omega-3s are good
and they come from fatty fish
and stuff like that.
But avocados and eggs
have a lot of omega-6.
Could you elaborate a little
bit on what the difference is
and why it matters, if
it does matter at all?
HALLIE RICH: So omega-6s
do get a bad rap.
But where you're talking
about things from food,
I wouldn't really
worry about it.
I mean, it's more kind of
my industry than the food
industry.
So when we're talking about
an avocado or anything that
has omegas in it, I wouldn't
worry at all about that.
I think that's a
manufactured controversy.
When you're talking
about supplements,
I would take an
omega-3 with a DHA
if that's something that
you're instead in taking.
That has EPA and DHA
for an omega product,
and I would stay away
from the omega-6s.
But when it comes to food.
I think it's a manufactured--
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Right.
I think the point
is our diet does
have a lot of
omega-6's in it just
naturally between
the foods we eat,
so there's no need to add
to it with a supplement.
Avocado and eggs, I don't know
if they have omega-6's in it
now that I think about it.
But I know certain oils do.
So I'd have to look that
up, because I've always
thought avocados and
eggs had the omega-3s.
So we're just saying in
general, the food supply
does have omega-6s,
so there's no reason
to take an extra
omega-6 supplement.
In fact, we need more omega-3s
to balance out the 6s.
HALLIE RICH: And with that,
if you're looking again
for a supplement, take something
that has EPA or DHA in it.
And if you get like
those digusting
ferd-- I can't even
speak-- fishy burps
from it or something.
There's different
ways to take it.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Nine
months pregnant.
HALLIE RICH: Yeah, sorry.
Pregnancy brain is a real thing.
We get to that in our
book, and you can always
email either one of us if
you have specific questions
about any of that stuff.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Thank you.
And right, everybody.
HALLIE RICH: Thank you guys.
ILYSE SCHAPIRO: Yes, thank
you so much for having us.
[APPLAUSE]